Hi, good morning.
So do you have a full day class
today?
OK, OK.
We'll wait for a couple of more
minutes and then we'll get
started.
So assume people are on
vacations and so on.
Maybe we'll not have a very
large strength.
Yeah, yeah, I have just replied
to you the clip.
Yeah.
So I will be posting after the
class.
Yeah, after every class
immediately you would be seeing
the PPT, but not before the
class, yeah.
Yeah, Amit, go ahead.
But in my recordings, all the
that I write on the slide will
also be available.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
So in the webinar I had seen a
discussion that you know what
the TA route.
I mean Soujanya had return
something I believe, but that
was not visible in the
recording.
Yeah, only the presentation and
her voice was available.
So I'll ensure that you know
that doesn't repeat.
Yeah.
What do you mean by that Amit?
Recording of the lecture.
Sometimes not able to see due to
your Internet issues.
What you mean?
Was the recordings are coming
out fine?
What about others?
You watch the recordings and is
it all fine?
Hi, good morning.
Yeah, it should be fine so.
Yeah, maybe not.
PT is given again and again and
repeat.
Please go to announcement.
Go to the course page and in the
main announcement right where
you had seen webinar one is
today there was a you know
announcement in that same
announcement.
If you go in, the presentation
is updated as a comment there,
yeah.
Yeah, download option is
available.
I mean the only option is to
actually view it or there is
another option for, you know
viewing it offline?
Maybe you can just, you know,
drop in an email and I'll loop
you into that DC OPS team and
they will assist you.
Yeah, within the app it should
be possible.
Yeah, without Internet it will
work, but you cannot download it
outside the app.
OK.
Other questions or one question
is there only one type of crew
which is binary or we can have
other categories also as free?
Yeah.
So binary is only one, right?
So if it has only, you know,
maximum two children, then that
is binary.
But we are putting again
constraints on strict binary
complete binary and all that.
So they're all different types
of binary.
Only then, right.
Because firstly they are binary
and then on top of it you have
some other rules like complete
binary tree, right?
So the word itself has binary
again, right?
So on top of binary, if you put
other constraints, they become
other categories.
Yeah.
Which one do you want me to
show, Amit?
I'm not sure about it.
Let me just quickly share my
screen.
You mean the webinar
presentation?
Yeah.
Let me know once the browser is
visible.
Yeah.
So this is our core speech.
Just go into announcements and
this there is a webinar 1 today,
you know which was posted on
21st December.
If you go into it, there is a
comment here which says please
find the webinar PPT.
Yeah.
And the recording or as usual,
available in teams. Cool.
And that in app download, maybe
you can just try to the you know
DSC OPS and they will support
you, yeah.
We'll wait for another minute
and then we will get started,
yeah.
Yeah, you should have received
all these long back, but I'm not
sure why there is confusion even
now.
So when you join the program,
you would have got all these
details in your email.
Yeah, this is Damien.
You can just try to them asking
how do you do offline in app you
know.
Download for that without
Internet you can watch, yeah.
OK, there was a question on
this.
Yes, give me a minute.
That any inputs for our midterm
exam, what all resources we
should refer to the operation?
Yeah.
So very first thing would be to
attend classes or if you have
missed it, watch the live
recordings and also go through
the PTS and every presentation
of mine has some practice
questions.
Practice them.
That is your second step, so
this is this whole thing is the
first step right where you are
aware of all the materials you
have learned all the concepts.
You've also put some, you know,
practice on those questions.
There will be your first step.
The second step would be to go
to your textbook and read some
concepts.
If you're still not clear, you
know, practice some questions
and so on.
And the third step would be to
go beyond your textbook where
you go to your CRS textbook or
online resources and so on.
And what I would be also doing
is exactly after the last class,
right after our eighth session.
I'll also be uploading a sample
paper.
Right.
I'll not be providing any key
for it.
It's up to you to, you know,
solve it.
Discuss among yourselves, and so
on.
But it's just a sample.
Yeah.
So the nature of these exams are
key, you know, varying.
I mean, last couple of years it
was offline, it was online, it
was offline again it was closed
book, it was open book. Many
combinations.
Yeah, it was.
For 40 marks, it was 30 marks.
So don't go with any of those.
You know, assumptions.
Just treat it as a plain
question.
Try to solve them and that would
be also helpful.
That will be our last step.
Yeah.
Yeah, we will do that, Rishi.
Yeah, every class we have been
doing today as well, we'll do
that.
Yeah.
Is that clear for all of you?
Just two weeks prior exams, I
would and of course.
Uh, D3D will be the last exam.
Traditionally, that's been the
case this time as well.
I I am sure that will be the you
know case.
So after the last session, which
is uh, in Jan, I will upload uh.
The questions hope so.
I don't know why.
Uh, I see this chat bubbles
these days.
I have turned it off but still I
see it.
But no, the problem with sharing
it sooner is it'll create a lot
of confusion.
Uh, because we have not covered
a lot of conflicts yet.
So and it will also put
unnecessary things into your
mind.
So the right time would be after
we completed classes and don't
take it very seriously.
There will be no questions
repeated and you know things
like that.
So just treat it as yet another
paper and maybe solve it while
you know.
Prepare for the exam.
Right.
Don't give too much importance
to you know these sample paper
sparse papers and so on.
As long as you have understood
the concept, you will enjoy
writing the paper, yeah.
Cool. I think.
Then let's get started.
So welcome to the 6th contact
session for data structures and
algorithm design, and today we
will start a new topic which is
the direction to graphs.
But before that, we will have a
recap of what we did in the last
class.
We will also see one more
application of heaps which is
called priority queues and after
this we will get started with
graphs.
We will see what is a graph,
what are the types of graphs,
terminologies, how do you
represent a graph and so on,
right.
We will do that.
So firstly, uh, how many of you
remember what we did in the last
class?
Yeah, real quick.
Do you remember what we did?
There are some hints here.
Right.
Heaps parity cues?
Yeah.
What exactly did we do in heaps?
Heap, heapsort, insertion,
deletion and heaps.
Yeah, heapify acation.
Yeah, a lot of you know,
interesting things we did.
So what did we really do?
So we started with what is the
heap and it's types and we got
it very clear that there are
only two types of heaps.
Yeah, there is a Max heap or
there is a min heap.
It cannot be both.
Yeah, it is either a Max heap or
a min heap or it is not a heap
at all.
Cool.
And what is a heap?
It is a tree based data
structure which has two
properties.
One is the shape property and
one is the heap property.
The shape property means firstly
it should be a complete binary
tree.
If it is not a complete binary
tree, there is no point in
talking about heaps.
You can right away tell this is
not a heap.
If it is a complete binary tree,
then it can either be a min heap
or a Max heap, or not a heap at
all.
If it's a min heap like this,
you know that for every parent
child relationship the parent to
smaller than the children right
one is smaller than four and
12:12 is smaller than the team
four is smaller than five and
10, and so one for every parent
child.
They should hold true, but as in
Max, the parent will be greater
than its children, 9 is greater
than 7966, is greater than 37,
is greater than four than two,
and so on, right?
And how do you represent a heap?
Since it's always a complete
binary tree, you can just use an
array based representation where
you will start the route from
one.
It's child is 23456 and so on.
So we learned about what is the
min heap.
What is a Max heap?
Then we learned term called
hippie fication, which is an
umbrella name.
Yeah, don't get confused at all.
There's a lot of jargons here,
but it's very simple.
Actual concept, yeah, I fication
is just a name.
Yeah.
What is that really mean?
It's simply means you are given
a complete binary tree, but it
is not a heap, but you want to
make it a heap.
Yeah, maybe you want to make it
a Max heap.
Then you will apply something
called as Max CP5.
Let's say you want a min heap.
You will apply Min Heapify and
as a result what you get will be
a Max.
See forum in heap and this whole
process of converting a non heap
into a heap that is called as
epic fication.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yeah, I saw some discussion also
on, you know, if fiction
bubbling and so on.
Yeah.
So I ping to make Maxwell
Mathew.
Exactly right.
Time complexity of min heap is
1.
Max Heap is log in.
No, no, no.
It's all the same, so it is log
in right?
So just fetching the root is
actually we go off one that is
for both.
We need power, Maxim.
You're directly going and taking
the first element that is a
constant, whereas any other
search Oregon insertion,
deletion, et cetera are log in
in both the cases.
Yep.
And then we started looking at
building a heap, right.
How do you build a heap?
There were two techniques.
One is using bottom up approach
using appropriate typification,
meaning if we are given the list
of numbers and if we are told
create a heap, what we can do is
we can just create a complete
binary tree out of it randomly.
Just create a complete binary
tree and then start performing
either Max CP5 or min EP5 based
on what you want.
If you want a Max heap, you will
apply Max CP5.
If you want a min heap, you will
apply min heap P5, meaning you
can build a heap using heapify
ication right?
That is 1 technique or you can
use repetitive insertion,
meaning you add one element
immediately you try to swap it
and make it as a heap that you
want.
Let's say Max Heap again, third
element you insert, you see if
it is a Max heap.
If it is not immediately, you
swap and make it a Max heap.
So like that you keep doing
after every insertion, so that
is also another way to build a
heap and then insertion.
We saw that, you know, you
cannot just randomly insert
anywhere you like.
So what is the criteria that you
need to keep in mind?
You remember that?
So for example, in this tree,
where is the only place where I
can insert?
Yeah, real quick.
Because I'll have to know root
is wrong.
What is the only place where I
can insert?
Yeah, we are not talking about
delete.
Yeah, the last leaf.
Where is that the right side of
12, right, right side of 12 is
the only correct answer.
You cannot insert left or right
of five left or right of 10
etcetera.
Why?
The reason is that we should
still maintain it to to be a
complete binary tree fate.
So if you draw to the right side
of 12, any number that is still
a complete binary tree, whereas
if you add it to as the children
of 510 or 13, then it is not a
complete binary tree.
So this position was called a
zit, right?
Z is an insertion position.
You will find such a way that it
still is a complete binary tree.
You will go ahead and insert it,
but the moment you insert it, it
might not be a heap, right?
Simple policy.
If this is a min heap after my
insertion also it should be a
min heap.
I should ensure that it is a min
heap.
But let's say suppose I'm going
to insert an element here which
is 0.5.
Yeah, that's also valid.
Yeah, it's .5.
I've added it here the moment
I've added it.
Will it be a min heap 12 will be
greater than .5 then this is
violating right?
So this will not be a min heap.
So what I should be doing?
I should again be doing the same
thing, swapping right, but in
this case when I'm doing
insertion, that's swapping has a
special name and that is what is
called a peep bubbly, meaning
this guy who got inserted at the
bottom, he bubbles up to his
proper place.
Yeah, he goes up to his proper
place, meaning .5 will
eventually become the root.
And it's children will be, you
know, others.
So that is called API bubbling
and deletion.
What is the only element that
you can delete which is the
root, but they're?
Also, we learned a lot of
interesting concepts that if you
just delete the route, what will
happen there?
I mean this whole tree will
become disjointed.
They'll become an orphan.
So you should take the last leaf
and put him there.
And if you do so almost, it is
very certain that it will
violate the heap property.
Just think logically, right?
So if this is a Max heap, the
largest element will be on the
top.
These smaller elements will be
somewhere in the bottom and if
you delete this route and
randomly put this last leaf
there, definitely it will not be
a Max heap right?
It'll violate the property.
This three if it goes up, it
will not be greater than seven
and six.
So in that case, again you will
perform swaps, so that is why
this is called down heap public
meaning this node which went on
top to the root, it will again
bubble down to its proper
position, right?
That is pretty much about
deletion, and then we also
learned about one application
which is heapsort.
Heapsort.
Very simple.
It had two phases.
Whatever numbers are given,
create a heap and then delete
everything.
What you get as a result is a
sorted order, right?
You're a couple of questions
will be asked.
Which one is good immediate
reapplication while insertion or
doing reapplication at last
after making binary?
Very good question.
So if you see here, we had
learned the complexity of both
of them right.
The first one is big of yen,
right?
You remember it was log and so
on, but we also told you can do
amortized analysis and we
convince ourselves that whatever
numbers are given, if you just
create it as a complete binary
tree and perform hippie fication
that is this technique bottom up
technique, the complexity would
be be go of yen whereas in this
repetitive insertion the
complexity will be and log in
right because log N is nothing
but for insertion and you are
inserting an elements and the
two repetitive every time you
are checking if it is a heap or
not heap or not and you are
trying to correct it.
So this is more costly, right?
Repetitive insertion method is
more costly to create a heap
than the bottom up approach.
Pull parallel insert or delete
may not be possible in
application using heap.
No, it is not possible.
Yeah, one after the other
sequentially, only you have to
upload or I mean add and after
adding you have to check if that
is still a heap or not.
If it is not, you have to
immediately correct it.
So parallelly, if you want to do
then there can be confusion.
There can be race conditions,
you know, things like that.
Yeah.
So in this whole course, most
data structures that we see
would be sequential data
structures, right?
They are not suitable for, you
know, streaming data or you're
constantly getting some data
from a sensor.
How do you store it so such data
structures are not in this
course?
Yeah, you will learn it in ML
and other courses when you go to
the next semesters.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you heaps, yeah.
Yes.
No.
Maybe what is the heap types of
it?
Hippie fication building a heap
insertion and deletion, as well
as the application of heat,
which is heap sort, right?
I would again and again as you
please practice those exercises
and watch the recordings.
Yeah.
These are all very simple
concepts, but there are a lot of
jargons involved, so it might be
overwhelming.
So what's the recordings and
follow along and then it will be
even more clear.
Yeah, we'll have a look at the
second application and then we
will go to the next data
structure called graphs.
So what does this priority
queue?
Yeah, it is an application of
heap, but have we already
learned what is the queue?
And if you remember what is the
queue?
What paradigm does it follow?
Is it last in, first out or is
it first in, first out or yeah
it is FIFO, right?
Similar is right.
The first element which goes in
will be the first element.
To get out that banq example and
the tall example and all that we
have taken right.
So that doesn't normal queue and
we are also seen about what is
the circular queue where you
know after the last element you
again point back to the first
one and so on.
We learned about all that, but
now what does this priority
queue?
So priority queue is a data
structure for maintaining a set.
Yes, of elements, each with an
associated value called a key or
a priority.
Yeah.
So you can call it so each
element in that data structure
and now is not just the element,
it is also going to have
something associated with it,
which is its priority.
You can call it as key or
priority.
I would prefer to call it as
priority.
Yeah, across my slides.
Whenever I'm talking, I'll talk
in terms of priority.
So the moment you now talk about
this priority, there is no real
fee for rule anymore, meaning
now the whole insertion,
removal, all that will not
happen based on first come first
serve or first in first out.
Yeah, it will happen based on
the priority of each element.
Yeah, there are two kinds now.
Again, Max priority queue and
min priority queue according to
Max 7 min heap.
So if you use a Max heap and
create a priority queue that is
called as a Max priority queue
and if you use a min heap and
create a priority queue that is
called a min priority queue.
And the key denotes the
priority.
So firstly, we will take an
example of why we should use
this right?
So what is the Max priority
application?
And then we'll go back to that
slide.
Yeah.
So have you all done a course on
operating systems or have a fair
idea how our operating systems
work?
Yes.
No, maybe.
It can be Windows, Linux, Mac OS
or whatever, but a general idea
of how our operating systems
work.
Yeah.
Do you have some idea?
He also real quick. Yeah.
So you have CPU.
Let's assume I'm a poor guy.
I just have a CPU, one CPU.
Yeah, I'm not using some
advanced, you know, laptops with
multicore and so on.
I have just one CPU and there
are many jobs in my computer,
right?
For example, I have my MS Teams
open and I have my browser open.
I have files open.
Many of these are programs, and
in OS terms it's called less
processes.
I'm running multiple of these
things right?
They're all in the queue.
They're all in the Reddy queue.
OK, so there are many concepts,
so let's not go into operating
systems, but I'm trying to just
tell you that even if you have
one CPU, you can run multiple
jobs.
Yeah.
Meaning it cannot run parallelly
at the very same time unit.
They will not be running, but
they'll quickly switch between
them and it is so fast that for
a human eye it will seem as
though all of them are running
right.
For example, PPT will run within
a microsecond.
Again, it will switch to MS
Teams and then it will switch to
browser and so on and it will
keep happening.
This is called context
switching, so all this the
operating system does it for
you.
But this Reddy queue this has a
lot of jobs now and this Reddy
queue can be implemented as a
Max priority queue.
Meaning the higher priority jobs
will get the CPU 1st and then
they will execute.
They will either get swapped
out, maybe they want to print
something or they want some IU.
They will go out.
They'll wait for that to happen
and they'll again join back the
queue.
Or if they have completed it,
they will go ahead and exit,
right?
They they are completed and they
will just exit the system.
So now this queue is behaving as
a priority queue.
Meaning, if there are five jobs,
I should go ahead and pick that
job.
Who's very important or having a
maximum priority?
So this short term scheduler is
a guy who picks up jobs from
this queue and gives it to the
CPU.
Got it right.
So there are many jobs here and
the CPU is now free.
This short term scheduler is the
guy who will decide which job
should go and execute in the CPU
next.
But say there are 10 jobs here,
right?
I should pick one among those 10
and give it to the CPU.
But which one do I pick?
If it's a normal queue, which
one will get picked?
Yeah.
Real quick, guys, all of you
just focus, yeah.
These are all just applications
I'm talking about.
Amit, please watch the recording
again.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
If it was first come, first
serve, the first job will come
and get executed in the CPU.
But I don't want that because in
my laptop or in all our laptops
it is not always first come
first serve.
There may be some higher
priority job which needs to be
executed right?
For example, say my laptop's
power is going, you know low.
Low then definitely I need a pop
up in my screen telling that you
know your power is going low.
Please, you know, put it in
charge so that type of a job
that becomes more priority to
me, right, it has to be executed
now.
So the whole job scheduling in
your laptops happen based on
priority.
Is this concept clear for all of
you, Amit? Yeah.
So I I made a lot of, you know,
other stories, but that is the
crux.
Yeah, our laptops scheduling
happen based on priorities.
Yeah, there are many other
scheduling also like round
Robin.
There's that, but let's not go
too deep into all that.
But here using a normal queue is
not a good idea.
Yeah, if you use a normal queue
then what would happen is just
jobs will keep coming and based
on the order they came they will
execute.
But we don't want that.
Yeah, we want jobs which are of
higher priority to execute 1st
and that is when I can use the
Max priority queue right?
So if you again go back to the
slide, job scheduling on shared
computer jobs have priorities
are stored in a Max priority
queue, right?
Each time a new job is to be
scheduled, it's got to be one of
the highest priority, right?
But how it is a queue then as it
can nullify the concept of
queue.
Yeah, this is called a priority
queue.
Yeah, so this is not a normal
queue, correct the the the
normal fee four thing is the
actual queue.
So here you can imagine it to be
a Max priority queue.
You are again calling it queue
because it is a linear data
structure, right?
And it has the similar concepts
of N queuing, dequeuing and all
that.
But you are right, you cannot
actually call this as a normal
queue or FIFO, right?
This is a special type of a
queue, so each time a new job
has to be scheduled, it's got to
be one of the highest priority,
highest priority in a Max heap.
Where will that highest priority
be?
Yeah.
Yes, try to remember if you have
a Max heap, where will the
largest element be?
Yeah, very good root, right.
So if I implement a Max priority
queue using a Max heap, then the
largest or the highest priority
one will be the first element or
the root element.
So always I can just pick that
one and give it to the CPU,
right?
And new jobs can be inserted
using the insert operation,
right?
This is exactly, you know, our
insert operation in a heap in
order to avoid starvation,
priorities can be increased.
Yeah.
Again, this is another concept
and operating system where we
just spoke about this priorities
and so on, right.
For example, there is this.
B1P2P3P4P5 all of these, and
they all have associated
priorities, right?
For example, this is of priority
10 is of priority eight.
This is of say 9.
This is of seven.
This is of, you know, 11 and so
on.
So at this stage, who will be
the one who will get executed?
I'm talking about Max priority
queue, meaning the process with
the highest priority, right?
So P1 will execute, then P5 will
execute, then P3 will execute
and so on. Right?
Let's let's assume this.
Yeah.
And let's say this guy executed
this guy executed and at that
time there is a P6 coming and
he's coming with a priority of
12.
So at this time, who will
execute be when already
completed?
If I already completed and now
it was the chance for P3, but
suddenly P6 has come now so he
will get executed and then P3 is
executing, yeah before is about
to execute.
But then there is another
process coming with again a
priority of say 11, right?
So he will get executed, but the
Speed 2.
If you see here, he has a lower
priority.
So he kept on waiting.
Yeah.
And these type of jobs are
coming with higher priority,
right?
So this particular case is
called as starvation.
Well, so when higher priority
jobs keep on coming, they are of
higher priority.
So they will get the CPU, they
will execute and go.
But what about the sad guys?
They came early, but their
priority is low so they will not
get the CPU.
They will keep starving.
They're starving for the CPU.
They don't get the CPU, they
keep waiting, right?
So what is 1 possible solution?
You get the point, right?
All of you, the very simple
line.
When higher priority jobs keep
coming, they hamper the
execution of lower priority
jobs, so lower priority jobs are
set to be starving for the CPU.
What I've already existing, you
know, process has the same
probability, then the new
priority.
Yeah.
Then it just the CPU.
This short term schedule is a
very intelligent guy, so he will
try to see who's you know, more
important based on, you know,
not just the priority but how
long have they been waiting and
how long will they take the CPU.
Right.
A very interesting course.
Yeah.
So next, I mean Sunday mornings
it this course to like small
kids types.
So yeah, so even two priorities
are two jobs.
Are there 2 processes are there
with equal priority?
Then this short term scheduler
will see other metrics right?
For example, this is going to
use the CPU for five
millisecond, but say this is
going to use for say 20
milliseconds, then maybe it's
worthwhile to get this guy going
right?
So that he can quickly complete
and leave and then I will give
it to him.
Or there are other metrics like
what other resources he need?
Does he have all the resources
needed and all such activities?
Yeah.
Cool.
So far so good, all of you.
But the point here is, did you
understand what is starvation?
Yeah, starvation is basically
they're just waiting and
starving.
So one possible solution is if I
increase this lower priority
jobs priority then he will
eventually become highest right?
Then he will get the CPU correct
meaning.
So if I change this seven, he
has a priority of seven, right?
I saw that for a long time he
has been waiting.
So what I will do is I will
change his priority to 8 again
if new jobs are coming with high
purity, they'll keep executing
and this guy will keep waiting.
What I will do is I'm again
feeling pity for him.
What I will do is I'll change
his priority from 8 to let's say
suppose 15.
The moment I do 15, he will have
a higher priority.
So the next or very next few.
You know jobs.
He will go into the root and he
will get executed.
So this whole concept is called
aging.
Aging is a solution to
starvation, meaning based on the
age of the job, you try to
increase their probability and
when their priority is
increased, they will eventually,
you know, become the highest
priority and they will execute
on the CPU, right?
So that is called.
That is nothing but increasing
the key, right?
So if you see here Max Heap is
used to implement a Max priority
queue, min heap is used to
implement a min priority queue
in Max Heap or Max parity queue.
Always delete and return an
element with maximum priority,
which is nothing but the root
which is nothing but the first
element A of 1, right?
That is where the highest you
know priority element will be
there.
Always remove this guy and give
it to the CPU.
That is the whole concept here.
Similarly in min heap it will
use the minimum as priority
right.
For example, in windows some
versions of Windows higher the
number, higher the priority
right?
So 10 means it is greater than
if I right where is in some
operating systems 5 is higher
priority than 10/1 is very high
priority.
Something like that, right?
So in that case you can use a
min heap and in other cases you
can use a Max heap.
What is?
Uh, the used for min priority.
Yeah, same concept.
Yeah.
So some operating systems, as
they told Linux and so on.
There, the smaller the number,
the higher priority, right?
If there are P1P2P3, if this is
having priority five, this is
having three.
This is having one.
This is the highest priority,
right?
So in those cases you can use a
min priority queue.
Cool.
So, so far so good.
All of you, this operating
system thing. Yeah.
So if you want a Max priority
queue, you will use a Max heap.
If you want a min priority
queue, you will use a min heap.
Is that clear?
Because you want the route to be
maximum priority in a Max heap,
right?
And in a min heap it will be the
lowest.
So based on waiting time, we
would increase the priority.
But what if we increase the
priority of job?
What is actually a low priority
if it conflicts with the new
priority?
Yeah.
Again, the same thing.
If there are two jobs, you know
having the same priority, the OS
will see other metrics and try
to schedule them.
Yeah.
Again, this is all OS cores
guys.
I don't want you to get too much
into all this.
Yeah.
So I just wanted to give you an
application of where this is
used.
Yeah, that's pretty much, yeah.
Yes.
No, all of you are clear.
Yeah, I would.
I would urge you.
There is a very, very good
textbook for operating systems.
Yeah, by operating system
fundamentals by Galvin and
others.
So you can actually go deep into
it if you're interested in
these, there will be no
questions on these in the exam
and so on because these are all
pure operating system concepts.
The the reason why I had kept
this is to show you where this
Max priority queue is useful.
So the baseline is it is useful
when you are going to have
certain priorities associated
with your elements and you want
to do all the operations based
on that priority eight.
One such example is the
operating system, right?
But there could be other cases.
Yeah, maybe.
For example, I associate a rank
with all of you, right?
Based on your marks for all of
you have given a rank and then I
tell you based on your rank only
you can ask questions or based
on your rank only you can, you
know, try to meet me in my
office hours.
Then you will use a priority
queue, correct?
Because you if you had used the
normal queue, it is fee 4,
right?
The one who gets up early in the
morning.
Who comes to the office?
They can quickly meet me.
Whereas now I have put some
ranks associated.
I'm telling that, you know, the
students who need more time or,
you know, more help from me who
have a lower rank.
They'll be the ones who have to
come first to me.
Right then I'm introducing some
priorities on how they will come
and meet me, right?
So if you want to model this use
case, you will use a priority
queue.
Yeah.
Is this application now clear?
Yeah, maybe that's a good idea.
Maybe I will remove all these OS
slide from this deck.
Yeah, from the next time.
Yeah, each student is associated
with the rank and based on your
rank only you can come in.
Meet me and clear your doubts.
Right then, that rank becomes
their priority, right?
And then both the ways I can put
the rule, I can tell that you
know people who have a lower
rank, they can come first
because they need more time to
be.
I can use that or I can tell
that the top rankers can come
first.
So if you want the top rankers,
you will use a Max priority
queue, right?
Right.
Maximum rank people will come
first or you can use a min
priority queue where the minimum
rankers will come in with me
first.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yeah.
What is Max parity mean priority
and you can have a couple of,
you know, uh operations on it
like you can do insert, right.
Obviously you can insert a new
element X.
Yeah, maximum returns the
element with largest key and
where will that be?
If it is a Max priority queue,
it'll be at the root right.
Maximum will only return it to
you, it will not remove it,
correct?
It will just tell you what it
is, right?
Yeah, there is no difference.
Jagdish, it is actually the
same, only it is just the way we
implement it.
Yeah, but both are actually the
same concept.
Yeah, that is why I'm just
talking about maxi mean heap.
You can just, you know, take the
opposite of it, where you will
take the lower value, but it's
exactly the same extract, Max.
It not just tells you who's the
maximum, but it also removes it.
It will remove it again the root
only right.
It will remove it and give it to
the CPU.
Increase key increase access key
to a new value K right?
For example, this is adding a
current priority of five.
I want to increase it to say 10
so this will be the new K value,
assuming K is at least as large
as ex.
Is old, right?
Yeah, I mean, uh, this is at the
end a set of elements, right?
So a set or sequence of
elements.
That is why we are using a set
and in a lot of times as you
told, we might not want to allow
duplicates, right?
We don't want multiple elements
with the same key, right?
If 10 elements are there, if all
of them have the same priority,
then there is no point in having
priority, right?
Your similar example I want to
have all of you given different
ranks.
I don't want hundred people to
have, you know, rank one right.
I don't want to do that, so if
you give this word set set means
you cannot have duplicates,
right?
But yeah, again, you're doing a
master's course. Guys.
Yeah.
So don't go by the slide or the
textbook, and so on.
You can actually implement and
Max priority queue using a
normal array.
Also in that case you will be
able to allow duplicates.
Also, you get it right Vinay.
Yeah, that's that word is used
here because this is a
mathematical set.
If you use a mathematical set,
you cannot have duplicates here,
so we are then telling that in
my Max priority queue I am not
going to allow jobs with same
priority, correct?
This is what this definition
means, right?
But if I don't want to use this
word set, if I'm telling insert
element X into.
Reddy this definition simply
means that I'm going to
implement this Max priority
queue as a heap only, and I'm
going to allow duplicates.
I can have 2-3 jobs with the
same priority.
Yes.
No, all of you.
Is it clear?
So it is all based on the
definition and our needs.
Yeah.
So don't go by the textbooks.
Yeah, a lot of times, even
eminent professors make those
mistakes that the textbook is
just an authors perspective,
right?
So if your application doesn't
require multiple jobs to you
know have a same priority, then
of course you can implement it
in that way and that is the
whole beauty of programming
right.
Instead of a set or something,
you will implement it as an
array.
You will implement it using the
heap only, which is the Max heap
and you will not put any
constraint.
You can actually allow multiple
jobs to have the same priority.
Yeah.
Is this clear? Yeah.
So Min priority queue will offer
insert minimum, extract minimum
and decrease key right.
The exact opposites of these
methods.
Keeps our very convenient here.
Using Max Heap, we know that the
largest element is in a of 1.
So just remove it and give it to
the CPU or you know any of that.
So it's a constant complexity.
Removing or inserting elements
and increasing keys means that
we are basically calling Max CP5
at the right place, correct?
Because anytime you insert
something, it might violate that
property.
So you will have to perform Max
CP5 so that it goes to its
proper position, right?
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you said, how about
percentile CPU usage percent,
how they are taken in priority
to kill the Max?
Yeah. That depends.
Yeah, it it.
It's larger than just to handle
in a one line answer.
So you're operating system uses
several techniques for CPU
management scheduling and you
know so on.
So priority is one of the
factors.
Yeah, but of course you can use
the priority queues to handle
these type of use cases.
So if I want to get the maximum,
what is the complexity?
Keep maximum will be nothing but
a of 1, which is constant
complexity.
If I want to extract the maximum
from the heap, what operation is
this?
Can someone clearly tell me that
I've already given the answer
here?
We want to extract maximum from
a priority queue.
It is nothing but a Max heap and
in a Max heap the largest will
be in the root and that route
will be deleted.
So this is nothing but a
deletion use case deletion from
a heap.
Yeah, and deletion from a root.
What is the complexity login
right?
Because you delete the route and
then you put that last leaf
there and then it will perform,
which bubbling will it perform?
It is going from top to bottom
right.
Yes.
No down he bubbling will happen.
So all that is happening, that
is, what is this code?
Yeah, I will.
I will urge you to look at these
code later, but don't go too
deep into it, but this part is
technically nothing but deleting
from a heap.
I've also, you know, I'll be
uploading that Python notebook,
so it'll be even more clear than
these code, yeah.
That increase heap example for
you. Yeah.
So there is currently this is
the Max heap.
Can I also call this as a Max
priority queue?
Now yes, no.
If I just convert this into an
array, right?
This can be called as a Max
priority queue and based on the
priorities the CPU or you know
that scheduler will pick him
correct.
So in this case, who is the job?
Who is going to get executed
next?
So all these numbers are
priorities of jobs.
Yeah, there are many jobs here
and each of them is the
priority.
So which job will execute next?
Very good.
The job with priority Sixteen
will execute, meaning I will
delete him.
I will give him to the CPU and
then this one will go there and
then I will perform the
complete, you know, don't be
bubbling and then who will be
the job next if you do all that
systematically, then 14 would
have become the next route,
correct.
He will go to the CPU next and
so on.
It will keep happening now.
There is this guy who has a
priority of four.
Sadly, new jobs keep on coming
and they are having high
priority, right?
So he will not get executed for
a long time, right?
So what I want to do is I want
to change this priority from 4
to 15.
So what I've done?
I've just changed this 4 to 15.
The moment I do this after this,
this is as good as insertion of
a new element with priority 15
only correct.
I will again perform the same,
you know, bubbling SO15 will get
swapped, 15 will get swapped and
so on and he'll go to this
proper position like this.
And now the next time after this
job executes, 15 will be the
next job, so he will get the CP,
just know all of you.
Yet these summer and Amit, all
of you really get this.
The only thing is after you
change this value to a new
value, it becomes as good as
adding a new element and then
you will again perform the same
you know public.
What will happen to job for job
four is still there?
Yeah.
So you guys got slightly
confused.
So for example, I'll have to
write it like this.
There is this job.
Who as a priority for the job is
still here, but his priority got
updated from 4 to 50, so that
was still there.
Exactly.
This is upbeat.
Public perfect.
Yeah, your bank on.
So this 15 will bubble up and
he'll go and execute.
So this updation is not very
different from insertion right?
So if you want to increase key
then of course the new key
should not be smaller than
current key, right?
If this element is 4, I should
not be updating with three or
one.
Then I'm doing bad.
I'm actually not helping that
job, so I should not do that.
Otherwise, what I can do is I
will just, you know, try to
increase his key, which is
nothing but insertion into the
heap.
And when I want to insert
something then I can use this
same code also.
That's a very clever way of
doing, but if you don't want,
just write this same lines again
here.
Yeah.
And again the same complexity
log in.
Uh, yeah.
The only rule in increase in the
keys, it should be greater than
the current key.
If it is 4, then the new key
should be anything greater than
four.
That's it.
Yeah, for one, it is down he
bubbling and for 15 it is
upheld, bubbling or no for both
of them.
Anything that goes from bottom
to up is upheld, bubbling right
and anything that comes from top
to bottom is down.
Heap bubbling.
Simple in this case 15 is or 15
or one.
Whoever it is, they are going to
go up.
So it is up heat bubbling,
whereas when I delete 16, what
will happen?
The last element will go there,
so one would have come here and
then he will again bubble down
to his correct position that is
called down he bubbling.
And again, I repeat, please
watch the recordings.
Yeah, every class from now on is
very related to previous
classes.
All this we have learned in
detail in the last class.
Yeah, Class 3 array is 16151014
and so on and 10 is less than
14.
Yeah, that's fine.
Yeah, that can always be there,
no problem.
But after 16 executes, this tree
would have got rearranged,
right?
And 15 would have gone to the
top right and after that there
will again be a rearranging,
right.
So that way it will get
corrected.
Yeah.
Why is it not a complete binary
tree?
Yeah, these are all complete
binary trees, right?
Anyone disagrees?
Yeah, real quick.
Can you confirm if this is a
complete binary or not?
Definitely yes, it is fully
filled in these levels.
The last level is from left to
right.
This is definitely a complete
binary tree, yeah.
Pull.
That being said, that completes
the priority queues.
Yeah, and some other
applications.
Heaps are used in heap sort.
It is used in priority queues.
It is used in order statistics.
Yeah, the heap data structure
can be used efficiently to find
the KTH the smallest or largest
element in an array, right?
Which we have seen several
times, even in the last class I
spoke about it, right.
You remember this example?
This is a Max heap.
You don't even know the numbers,
but I'm claiming that this is a
Max heap.
Where is the second largest
element?
Yeah, in a normal array, you
don't know where is the largest,
where is the second largest,
etcetera.
So you'll have two completely
traverse the array which is big
off yen.
Where is in a Max heap.
You very well know.
The largest is here in the root.
The second largest is somewhere
here or here, so this is level
0.
This is level one.
Yeah, all of you who told level
2 wrong.
Yeah, that is way again and
again.
I repeat, it's all about the
small nuances right.
We learned about terminologies
in one of our classes, right?
The root is always in level 0
then this is level one.
I know all of you got it right
in your mental model.
You told it as level 2, but in
quizzes and exams you will write
away lose marks there, right?
So don't do that.
So this is level one.
This is level 2, so your second
largest element will be in Level
1, which is nothing but these
two elements.
I'll have to just check these
two elements for the second
largest, which is going to be a
constant complexity for me, just
the if else condition right?
So in order statistics, heaps
are again helpful and heap
implemented priority queue,
meaning Max priority queue or
min priority queue are used in
many graph algorithms like PRIMS
algorithm which extracts
algorithm and so on which we
will learn in the later part of
this course yeah.
Yes.
No.
So far so good.
All of you and there are many
more exercises for you.
Again, yeah, try to do all of
these exercises and now we will
go with graphs.
Yeah.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe the applications.
Yeah.
What is a heap?
He pacification heapsort.
Priority queue.
All these concepts?
Yeah, so please try to know
again, go back the ways them
solve these exercises and you
know, start some discussion
threads and that will be really
fruitful. Yeah.
So let's go ahead with graphs.
All of you?
Yeah, real quick, maybe you can
react or gotten the chat.
This is a new data structure,
yeah.
Any of the leaf or fruit?
Yeah, that's correct.
Yeah.
What about others?
I just see, you know, saurab
another one or two folks.
Yeah, if you have not understood
something in the prior trees, go
back to the recording.
But now let's come back to
graph.
This is a new topic. Yeah.
So we'll focus on this one.
Yeah.
So what really is this graph?
A graph G is defined as a pair
of two sets V&E the moment
there is set.
What can you infer?
Can there be duplicates? Yeah.
Yeah, there is no deliverable.
These are all self try excesses.
I'm not going to police you.
It's up to you if you solve it
or not, and there is no
deliverable.
Absolutely.
Yeah, it's only for you to, you
know, solve it.
Where we the set of nodes called
as vertices and east is a
collection of pair of vertices
called edges.
Meaning all these circles?
Yeah, 123.
All these circles are called as
nodes or I can call it as
vertices.
Both are the same thing and all
these lines are called as edges.
Yeah.
So G is equal to we comma E in
this example we is nothing but
this circles 123456 and the
number of nodes are six, right?
Because there are six here, it
just is again a set, but it is a
pair of vertices, meaning I can
go from one to six.
There's an arrow here.
We'll come to this arrow in a
minute, but just one to six is
there, then one to two is there
and then two to three is there.
So all the lines we are
documenting the in a set and
that is called as edge.
These are the set of edges and
this whole thing is now called
as a graph.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you, it's not.
Though if you want to also know
a lot of background about this,
you can, you know, Google about
conics. Bugs.
Bridge.
Yeah.
So there was a very interesting
problem in Europe and you know,
there was a scientist, you know,
Euler and so on, who had tried
to solve this and that is when
this whole concept of graph was
born.
And it is a very, very, very
important part of theoretical
computer science.
Your whole data science, your
advanced AI, ML, they all rely
on fundamental data structures
like graph and this is a
complete subject on its own
called graph theory.
Yeah, so this can be taught for
years together.
Yeah, this is a very, very
interesting concept.
There are thousands of
algorithms and things related to
this field and there is active
research even now.
But it all started here.
There were a set of islands.
There was A bridge and you know
things like that.
And then this particular
scientist converted that real
life problem into a graph.
And that's when this whole
concept of graph was born,
right?
It's a set of vertices.
It's a set of edges, yeah.
Let's take an example.
Yeah.
So this one is a graph.
A vertex represents an airport
or a vertex or a node.
Both are the same.
Represent the rapport and store
the three letter airport code
and enjoy the presence.
A flight route between 2
airports and stores the mileage
of this route right, for example
from Ord.
This is an airport and PVD is an
airport to go from PVD to OD to
PVD or from PVD to Rd.
It takes 849 kilometers, right?
Similarly for any other nodes,
so this is an example of a
graph.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yeah, you can model the same.
You know the whole, uh, Indian
domestic airports and you know,
kilometers and all that using a
graph will be able to do that.
Yes, simple stuff, right?
This is a small example.
Can you think of other examples
of graph modeling?
It's right.
Google Maps, Facebook and
friends, right?
Can I consider each profile to
be a node and the friendships to
be age?
Let's say suppose this person is
a friend with this person is a
friend with this person, whereas
he's not a friend with this guy,
right?
Yeah, it's all the same.
Yeah.
Summit.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
For example, this person is a
friend only with this guy, not
with others, right?
Can I model something like that
exactly Twitter user and tweets
likes all such, you know, things
worldwide.
Web and hyperlink?
Yeah.
Any web developers?
Yeah, you do web development.
Essentially, this is a web page,
right?
This is a web page.
You have a lot of content.
Maybe you have a link and that
link takes you to another web
page and there you might have
another link which can take you
another web page.
There can be a home button which
may again take you back to this
web page and so on.
So this web page is become the
nodes and these battles become
the edges, right?
And again, operating system
heavily uses you know your graph
concepts.
Electronics are cutes
transportation networks, right?
Computer networks, right?
Your whole you know LAN Internet
and one can also be, you know,
looked at as a web of, you know,
graph databases, ER diagram.
There is some concept, right?
They're also all entities are
in.
You know your you have
triangles, you know, arrows and
so on.
So that can also be looked at as
a graph.
Yeah.
Is this clear guys for all of
you, the motivation of what the
graph is and you know what is
the S edges and some examples of
it?
Is that clear?
And now we will look at a very
important aspect of what is the
difference between the tree and
a graph.
But right in a tree, there is
only one path between two
vertices, right?
So in all these trees that we
have been seeing, for example,
if I want to go to 8, the only
way to go is from 16 to 14 from
14 to 8, correct for any two
nodes that you pick, right?
For example, I want to go from 7
to 9.
What is the only route from 7 I
should go to 14 from 14 I should
go to 16 from 16 I'll go to 10
from 10 I'll go to 9.
The crux is for any two nodes,
there's only one path between
them.
You cannot have multiple paths.
Whereas in a graph more than one
path is allowed root node, it
has exactly 1 root node right
always in a tree there is a root
node, whereas graph doesn't have
a root node concept itself.
There is no dedicated root or
anything.
Yeah, loops are permitted in
graphs, whereas in trees it is
not permitted.
You can never have a loop at
all, right?
There is never a shape like this
in a tree, right?
Is this possible?
Because two parents cannot be
there for a child right in the
tree concept.
So you can never have a you know
cycle like this or a loop like
this in your trees.
But as in graph you can always
have this right.
For example, if you see here,
this is like a loop.
This whole thing is like a loop.
This is like a loop.
This whole square, like so many
things, are possible.
Trees are less complex compared
to graphs right traversal
techniques.
There are three techniques that
we learned pre-order in order
post order, whereas in graphs
there is breadth first and depth
first number of edges.
Very important.
Yeah, there is always this
relationship, which is in minus
one, right?
If there are number of nodes
exactly N minus one number of
edges will be there in a tree,
right?
I don't know if you have noticed
all this.
For example, I have a small tree
like this.
There's a binary tree correct?
In this I have 3 notes.
How many edges are there 2 edges
are there right?
This is 1.
This is 2 so there is this
relationship on any tree.
This will hold true.
Correct.
Whereas in a graph it is not
defined, I can have any number
right and model type.
Very important tree is used for
hierarchical representation,
right?
We kept on learning about that,
that, you know, hierarchy of
your organization and so on.
Right.
But as graph is used to model a
network type of a problem that
what is used to implement the
graphs?
Yeah, we will come there.
Yeah, that's the next part.
We will learn about it in many
ways.
You can implement. Yeah.
So we will learn about all that
traversal technique of graph.
Yeah, there are two.
One is called breadth first and
one is called depth first.
That is, for the next class, we
will in-depth learn about how to
do the traversal.
He just clear at a big picture.
What is a tree and what is a
graph?
Yeah, we will look at some
examples or some terminologies
and then we will take a short
break.
Yeah.
First things first, directed
Edge directed in meaning with
arrow right.
For example, here there's an
arrow.
It is an ordered pair of
vertices.
You comma V where U is the
origin and V is the destination.
For example, there is a flight
A1206 which goes from Ord to PVB
but does not return from PVD to
odd.
Is the one way flight.
Yeah, this is called as directed
H, meaning you can go from here
to here, but cannot come back.
Yeah, if you have a arrow, it's
called directed Edge undirected
edge or some people also prefer
to call it as bidirected
bidirected, meaning there is no
arrows there, meaning from Ord
to PVD.
Also, it is 849 miles from PVD
to Rd.
Also, it is 849 miles right?
So it is undirected or
bidirected.
There are no arrows in it.
It is an unordered pair of
vertices.
You comma V you can write it as
you comma V or you can write it
as V comma U.
Both are the same.
One cool.
And then you have directed graph
directed graph, meaning all the
edges are directed.
All the edges are directed.
If you have arrows, then that's
a directed graph.
If all the edges are undirected,
if you don't have any directions
right, that is a undirected
graph, right?
So flight networks are always
directed, meaning there's arrow
from where you know which flight
is going and so on.
It is undirected graph.
It says suppose a root example.
I can always have it as
undirected.
I'll give you some analogies.
Then it will be even more clear.
A road between two points could
be one way, meaning it is
directed.
You can go from point A to point
B, but maybe you cannot come
back one way.
Road is called as a directed
Edge A2 Way Rd is called, isn't
directed, meaning you can go
from A to B and you can come
back from B to a.
So I can represent it within two
arrows like this or I can
represent it with just a line
like this without any arrows,
which means I can go from A to B
as well as B to a right?
Can have more than one edge.
Is that also possible?
Yes, from A to BI can have like
this say 10.
I can have one more with say 20.
I can have one more with say 30.
So from A to BI can go either
using the road or I can use the
tall route or I can take a
flight route right?
So multiple roads are also
possible, so multiple edges are
possible between two nodes.
That is also possible.
So far so good, all of you.
Yeah.
Simple definitions, guys.
Yeah, you should not make
mistakes here.
Adults are directed edges.
No, arrows is undirected.
If a graph has only directed
edges, it is a directed graph.
If a graph has only undirected
edges, it is an undirected
graph.
We took some analogies also.
Right.
We'll complete this one and then
we'll take a break.
It is very simple.
End vertices of an edge.
Yeah, very important.
You are taking an edge in your
hand, meaning a line in your
hand and looking at who are the
two endpoints of it.
For example, if I pick up this,
A is nothing but this line.
This edge?
What type of an edge is this
real quick?
What type of an edge is that?
Is it directed or undirected?
Yeah.
Undirected, right?
Because there is no arrows.
Perfect.
So if I take it in my hand, I
look at who are the two
endpoints of it?
That is nothing but you and V so
I can call SU&V are end
vertices of a.
Can you quickly explain me who
are the end vertices of F?
Who are the end vertices of F?
Yeah.
WY very good.
Yeah, WY are the end vertices
of.
Yeah.
So end vertices we looked then
it just incident on a vertex.
So this is exactly opposite.
Here we pick up a node or vertex
and see who all all the edges
were touching me right.
For example, if I consider this
node V right, there is a who's
touching it there.
Is this B and there is this D so
AD&B are incident on V?
Yeah.
So can you tell me who all are
incident on? Why?
Who are the edges incident on?
Why?
Yeah, we all are touching.
A friend G. Yeah.
Perfect.
And then you have adjacent
vertices, meaning adjacent
vertices are two opposite ones,
right?
For example, you and we are
adjacent U NWR, adjacent W and
XR adjacent, hence 1.
So I SU&X adjacent.
I just said meaning 2 opposites
right?
You will be VWWXXZXY, et cetera,
right.
U&X are not adjacent is U NZ
adjacent?
It's no, what about you and Z?
Are they adjacent?
No, right?
Because they are not, you know,
opposites.
They are not connected as well.
Degree of a vertex degree of a
vertex.
Meaning, how many edges are
incident on that vertex.
For example, if you consider X,
there is this one.
There is this 2345 right 12345
so ex is degrees five.
What is the degree of V?
Can you tell me?
Number of edges incident on a
vertex.
So for V it is this one.
It is this two this is 3 so it
is 3.
Yeah.
Pull and then you have parallel
edges, right?
Parallel edges are nothing but
whose.
End work pieces are the same.
For example, for a H and I, the
end vertices are X comma Z or
you can tell it AZ comma X.
It's the same, right?
So for X&Z.
These two are the parallel
edges, so H&R parallel edges
right self loop Jesus self loop
self loop is something where the
end vertices is the same node
right?
So there's a subtle difference,
guys.
Parallel edges, meaning for H it
was Z comma X or you can tell it
as X comma Z and for I also it
was the same.
So it takes you to the same
source and destinations, whereas
a self loop is A1 which has only
one node.
Yeah, it goes to the same node,
yeah.
It's no did you get this self
loop?
J is an example right?
There's no no other parallel
loop.
Yeah, there is no other parallel
edge here, correct?
If I Draw Something like this
then there is a parallel edge
right from West to why there is
F and then I can also call it as
a P or whatever, right?
That is always possible.
Yeah.
Is it is a node?
That's all.
Yeah, that is a node who has a
degree of 1/2 and three.
Yeah.
So this whole self loop should
be counted as one only.
Yeah, you should not count as
multiple parallel element.
All road and public Rd.
Perfect.
Yeah, that's good.
Can you come up with a self loop
example?
Yeah, Speaking of that is 3
correct.
Yeah, because this is a self
loop, but some others will count
it twice.
That's also fine.
You can also tell it as four.
I cannot deny that poor is
wrong.
Yeah, it is this 123.
You can count this also then it
is 4, but technically you should
not count it because it's a self
loop.
Yeah, not even uturn.
Maybe I will give you an
example.
Let's say suppose you're all
rich folks.
Yeah, you have a duplex house?
Yeah, you have a duplex house
here.
You have the ground floor and
you have your steps and you have
your first floor.
This full is your house, yeah.
This steps is nothing but your
self loop.
It is taking you to the same
node only.
Is it making sense?
Yes.
No.
Maybe you have a house.
You're in the ground floor,
which is a node first.
Floor is also a node and this
steps is taking you from ground
floor to 1st floor but still you
are in the same house only
right?
So I can call that as a self
loop.
So far so good, all of you.
Oops.
Cool.
Then let's take a quick break.
It's 935 now.
We'll come back by 9:40 and we
will continue from there.
Yeah, I'll still be around if
you have any other uh queries or
any other general things we can
talk about it.
This parallel edge is present in
bidirected graph.
Yeah. It depends.
Yeah, it could be present.
It may not be present right?
For example, in this graph, if I
remove this H then there will
never be any parallel edges,
right?
It depends on our graph.
In both the cases it can be
there.
It might not be there.
Sir, can you please show me a
difference between tree in
postorder in tree?
I'm a bit confused.
OK.
So we just saw very simple
example also right.
If you have ABC here itself, you
will find the difference, right?
So if you have root left, right,
how do you can have left, right,
root or you can have left root
right?
So there will be differences.
One will be nothing but BAC.
He can have a beauty or you can
have BC.
So there is a difference.
But again, I urge you to solve
that question that I've given.
There was a bigger tree, right?
And the solutions are in the
slide itself.
So try to draw that and see.
You know, if you're able to
match it.
If not, we will again cover that
in the Web app.
Yeah, the coming baby now will
be taken by amisha.
So she will cover maybe this
again quickly, yeah.
But try to practice it before
the webinar so that the webinar
makes sense, yeah.
Yeah, reliance finance giving.
Yeah, that could also be an
exam.
Can you recap end vertices and
edge vertices?
No, there there is no edge
vertices at all.
Yeah, there is only end vertices
or edges incident.
Yeah, end vertices.
Meaning you are picking up a
node and seeing who are the two
endpoints of it, right?
For example, you pick up F and
you see F is an edge, right?
So you now see who are the two
end work tices of this.
That is nothing but WY simple.
Those are end vertices of age,
whereas edges incident, meaning
you are taking a node in hand
and seeing who all all the edges
were touching me.
That is nothing but A and C Now
Amit will answer me.
What are all the edges incident
on W?
Yeah.
Where all the edges incident on
W.
CD.
That's right.
And then because of that, what
does the degree of W then you
just mentioned, CDE.
So what is the degree of W?
It is 3 correct CDN E that is 3.
That is the degree of W then
that is the edges incident on a
vertex, whereas if you want to
know the end vertices, can you
tell me the end vertices of B?
Yeah.
I'll SRIDHANYA dos where quick
to find that and you'd also
correct.
So CDE&F is also touching
here, right?
So for DW the degree is 4 and it
is nothing but CDENF.
Amit, did you get this?
Yeah, VNX is correct, whereas
here in the edges incident on
it, you are careless here in
this side, you only looked at
the top.
And I was also, you know,
constantly.
Trying to, you know, go in the
same direction, but your friends
correctly pointed out that CDENF
for the IT just incident on it.
To tomorrow.
So do you have any classes?
OK.
OK, nice.
If it's directional, how will
the terminologies be impacted?
Sorry, it will not be impacted,
yeah.
It'll it'll still.
You'll have to just, you know,
concentrate on what?
The concept means right?
If you take a edge, if you look
at the two endpoint of it that
is end, what is?
If you look at, you know edges
incident will slightly vary
where there will be few more
definitions called in degree.
What this is and out degree in
degree means who's coming
towards you?
How degree means who's going
away from you?
Great.
When the time comes, you will
log.
Yeah, don't worry about that.
That I'm trying to reach
management via email ticket for
enabling online exams.
Since I have permanent residence
in uh. OK.
OK.
Ohh.
Or the best way to prioritize my
request?
Yeah, I can the same email ID
initially if you remember
SANTHOSH, I had put an email ID
right OPS you can write to them
and let's see you know that
should be faster than the
support ticket. Yeah.
Uh.
Due to much class work where we
in our office, uh no excitement
about New Year to have a class.
Tomorrow will not make a
difference.
Yeah, of course.
And to just add to that.
Non excitement.
You know what is today, right?
Ohh 5 emails.
OK, let me also drop in a word
to them to have a look at it.
Yeah.
Yes, that's right.
Krishna is bang on.
So you're D SAD.
First assignment will go Live
Today.
They are today's 30th December,
as I promised in the initial
announcement.
It will go Live Today.
Yeah, it'll go Live Today, and
it will be available till 14th
January.
End of day.
Yeah, that gives you exactly 15
days.
So try to get that going.
3rd when can we get all the
lecture slides till now and
canvas everything is available?
Yeah, just that you are looking
at in the wrong place.
I have repeated this right from
the Python class, so please
don't go here.
You are in Section 2.
You're in Section 1, right?
So you'll have to go into
section one and inside that you
will be able to see the slides.
Yeah, you're looking in the
wrong place.
Well, I think let's get started
and if there's any time left at
the end, how we can again chit
chat?
Yeah, cool.
Now, what is a part?
Yeah, that is very simple.
Yeah, it's a sequence of
alternating vertices and edges,
yeah.
Yeah, there were some questions.
Yeah.
We will take all those, you
know, things later.
Yeah, all of you back again, are
you back?
Other shared, you know, got an
important point.
So all of you your assignment
question will be a big PDF
document.
Yeah, for at least I'm not sure
about any other course, but for
this course you will have a PDF
document.
You will be working in groups.
First things first, download
that PDF.
Read every line of it.
I again repeat.
Please read every line of it.
There are many nuances given in
that and everything will be
given in the assignment.
The question the sample input,
the sample output, what is the
deliverable expected?
What type of files you need to
submit?
How should you name that file?
Every detail will be available
in that document.
It will be a good four to five
pages.
The question itself, yeah, your
solution might be just one page,
but the question is 4-5 pages.
I would urge you not to start
the assignment before reading
it.
Yeah, completely read the five
page document because there are
mishaps.
There is a way.
You need to name the assignment.
There is a way.
You need to, you know, submit a
format right?
For example, you need to write a
Python file.
You need to submit an excel
sheet whatever, right?
The evaluation will be.
Exactly as per the rubric.
If you have done the exact
correct solution, but you have
not named it according to the
Convention, you will get a zero.
Please do not write emails.
Don't you know?
Ask later that you know I have
done well.
I this was an oversight and so
on.
Ask me, the evaluation will be
exactly as per the rubric.
Whatever is given in the
document, it will be evaluated
on that.
Yeah, I'll not be.
You know, so evaluations.
I'll be ruthless in that exam.
Evaluation is different.
Yeah, of course all your answers
are encouraged.
If you are taking the right
direction, you might still find
marks, so I know some leniency
will be there, but this is an
open book.
You have 15 days of time and if
you have not read the PDF
document and if you make silly
mistakes like you know wrong
naming conventions or wrong
formats, right instead of a
Python file.
If you upload a Java file, it
will not be even evaluated.
Yeah, right away.
It will be even as a zero.
Yeah.
Is it clear for all of you?
Yeah, that's a good point.
That other Schmidt?
Yeah, it's not to scare you, but
that is the fact.
Yeah, there are plenty of times
I have done this and that is
share carelessness, right?
I mean, if you don't read the
question properly and if you
just start attempting it, and if
you make mistakes, then I mean
that's, you know, pure
carelessness.
Yeah.
Yes.
No.
Do you all agree that you will
read the full document and
adhere to that?
Yeah, I don't see any place.
Yeah, it will be a big PDF
document.
Read it fully every detail that
you need will be in that, yeah.
If you have any doubts while you
do your assignment, what do you
do right?
You should not write emails.
Yeah, you will read in that PDF
there is a way to ask the DAS.
Yeah, there will be a discussion
thread dedicated for every
question India.
One more thing is not all of you
will get the same question.
Yeah, it's a pool of questions.
Each group will get different
different questions, yeah.
Anything you write to me, uh,
no, nothing against that.
Yeah.
So I'm just warning you that
please be very careful that all
these subtle things also matter,
right?
So I understand that the bigger
picture is learning and you know
you want to solve the
assignment.
You need to have fun solving it
and all that completely agreed.
But still you are in an academic
framework, right?
You wear the hat of a student,
at least for some time, and it
is absolutely needed that you'll
have to adhere to these things
right?
Submitting a wrong document and
plagiarizing and then telling
that you know, unknowingly, I
copied, so those will not be
accepted, yeah.
Cool.
That being said, let's get
started again and we will look
at these.
Yeah.
And in the next class.
So before our end deadline, we
have another class as well.
So in that class I will again
open one assignment and explain
it as to what all are there in
the question.
Right.
Cool.
What is the path path?
Is a sequence of alternating or
kisses and edges right?
So what is that?
It begins with our text.
It ends with a vertex.
Each edge is preceded and
followed by its endpoints.
So again, there is.
So for example, I can just, uh,
just cook up an example for you.
He be be see something like
that.
This is an example of a path
right from a I'm taking this
edge and going to B.
Then I'm taking this edge C and
I'm going to D and so on, right?
Any of these I can do, which is
a path simple path path such
that all its vertices and edges
are distinct.
Let's take an example.
If you look at this P1 right,
how will you name this P1?
You started with V and then you
took B and from V you reached X
from X you reached H and from
high you went to Z.
So this is a simple path.
Yeah.
Path is very simple Raja.
You just start with some vertex.
You start going along a path
that is a path, right?
For example, if I start with V
from VI took this edge BI
reached X.
From there I took Ch.
I reached set so this is called
a path.
Is this clear?
Yes.
No, maybe.
Cool.
And in this path, once you wrote
it, are there any duplicates in
this?
Yes.
No.
Are there any duplicates?
No.
Then this is called a simple
path.
Now let me draw another path.
Yeah, look at it carefully.
This particular diagram right
you start with you.
You go to W and then to ex.
I go to G again, come back to
WI, go to V right.
If you write it in path, it'll
be like this, right?
You start it from you.
You went to the, you know, Etsy.
You went to W, you took the
edge, you went to X, took the
edge G, went to Y, took the
edge, F went to W then DEV.
So in this, are there any
duplicates?
Yep, peace.
Focus here, Raja.
All of you.
I'll show you again, this is the
end time I have shown, but
again, I'll show you later.
But now, please focus all of you
here.
Yeah, it's very important.
Yeah.
So in this there are duplicates
right?
There is a W here which is
repeating.
Correct.
So then this is not a simple
path.
Some people prefer to call it a
complex path.
Yeah, you know, what is the
cycle?
Circular sequencing, right?
Circular sequence of alternating
vertices and edges.
That is the cycle.
For example, let's draw that you
see the green one.
You start from B.
You take this route B.
You go from V2X to YY2WW to you
U2V.
So you started and rotated and
came back to the same place.
And here that last place you
will just mark it like this,
like an enter character.
It means that you came back to
the same place right from V you
went to X2Y2WW to you, and then
you took this A till this.
A.
You'll mention it.
It simply means you came back to
that same place and in this are
there any duplicates?
No, there are no duplicates, so
this is called a simple cycle.
Now let's draw another cycle.
Yeah, just like an 8, right?
It's going like this, right?
So if you see here from view we
went to W then to X, then to Y,
then to W, then to V again, you
are back here.
But in this also there is this W
that is repeating, so it is not
a simple cycle.
Yeah.
Is this clear?
Guys, all of you.
What is the cycle?
You start from our tax for a
node, you take a lot of edges,
you rotate and you come back
there right a triangle.
Also you can consider like that
right?
So you start from here.
You go.
Here you again go to this node,
you come back to this node.
This is also a cycle.
If you start, is it some other
nodes and come back to the same
node, that is a cycle.
It's no all of you and you just
react or put in.
The fact is this clear.
Both and cycle.
Cool.
Now let's look at this one
concrete example which has a lot
of concepts.
All these black dots are called
as nodes, correct?
This is an example of an edge
these lines.
Do you see this Gray color
highlighted portion here?
All of you are able to see this,
this part alone.
Or maybe I can highlight it for
you.
This part alone.
Right.
I can call it.
This is a path of length 4
because if you see here there
are four edges involved, right
this one.
This is 2.
This is 3.
This is 4, so this is a path of
length 4.
This is a cycle of length file,
right?
No, there is no self loop and so
on.
Yeah.
Yeah, self loop is a cycle.
That's right.
Correct, all cycles are not self
loops, but all self loops are
cycles.
Is that correct Chauhan?
So this is the cycle, right?
You start in this node.
You go to this part.
Go here.
Go here.
Come back. Right.
So this is a cycle, but this is
not a self loop.
Whereas if you have a self loop,
that's always a cycle, right?
I can have something like this,
so that's the cycle.
The vertex of degree three,
meaning this node has three
different edges, so it's degrees
three cool.
So this connected component will
come later.
Yeah, we will look at this
definition further.
But is this definition clear so
far?
What is a node or vertex?
What is an edge?
What is the degree?
What is the cycle?
What is it just incident on our
vertex?
All of this is it clear.
Amit, Simran, all of you.
OK, let's also look at some
graph types.
Yeah, this might be also
interesting.
This is called a null graph.
Yeah.
So all these are for your MCQS
and so on.
Yeah, a graph that has no edges
is called a null graph.
Yeah.
Can I say that all the planetary
system, maybe something like
stars?
Are they an all graph?
Is there paths between those
stars?
We don't know. Maybe.
Yeah, null graph.
What is another example that you
can come up with?
They're all nodes, but there is
no path between them, right?
Can I also consider some island?
Yeah, Ireland.
Also, you can always argue that
no there is a flight and all
that.
Right.
Cool reveal graph a graph with
only one vertex is called as a
trivial graph.
Yeah, what could be an example?
Yeah, getting consider the
universe to be a trivial graph.
Yes. No.
Which route?
The whole graph we are talking
about Krishna, right?
There's only one node in the
whole graph, right?
An example could be the
universe, right?
We don't know about Earth and so
on, but the universe probably.
Yeah, the whole universe can be
considered as one node, right?
That's the trivial graph
undirected graph.
You already know it, or I can
also call it is by directed the
graph that contains edges, but
the edges are not directed,
meaning I can go from A to BI
can go from B to a that's an
undirected graph directed graph.
A graph that contains edges
which have direction right from
A to BI can go, but I cannot go
back from B to a.
Is the question Simon asked.
Trivial graph will have one
node.
What about edges?
Is it 0 or any number?
It is 0 correct because not
having any edges at all.
Yeah, everything is encompassed
in that node alone.
That's it, right.
There are no edges.
Good.
What about a simple graph?
A simple graph is a graph that
contains no loops and no
parallel edges, right?
For example, in this, if you see
there are no loops in it.
I can start from a I'll go to C
I'll go to B, but I'll get
stuck.
I cannot come back to a right,
so there is no loop here.
There is no self loop here.
There is no cycle.
Also here there are no parallel
edges.
Also, right from between each
nodes they are only one edge.
There are no multiple ones, so
that is a simple graph.
It can have a self loop edge.
Which one swapna?
A simple graph cannot have it,
but which one did you ask?
Trivial graph.
No, trivial graph should not
have any edge.
Yeah, it is just one node.
That's that's a trivial graph,
right?
And many more.
Yeah.
So there are many, many types of
other graphs like, you know, uh
bipartite graphs, Hamiltonian
graphs, you know, things like
that.
So which of the below is a
simple graph even for a null
graph?
No edges, right?
Correct, but there you have
multiple nodes at least, right?
You have multiple nodes, but
they are not connected, whereas
in trivial graph number of nodes
itself is just one, yeah.
Which of the below is a simple
graph?
Yeah, 1 two or three.
Yeah, none of them is wrong.
This definition says no loops
only.
Yeah, no loops, meaning self
loop, no self loop, no parallel
edge cycle can be there.
First one very good it's a
simple graph.
What about the second one and
third one?
They're not simple, but why this
one is not a simple graph
because of which reason, because
of parallel edges between these
two nodes there is this edge.
There is also this extra
additional edge.
Similarly here there is a edge.
There is another extra edge
here, taking to the same nodes,
so there is a the non simple
graph with multiple edges or
parallel edges.
The last one it is not a simple
graph because there is a self
loop.
There are two self loops here.
Well, so are all these concepts
clear guys?
Node Vertex, Edge, directed,
undirected cycle path, degree
right adjacent self loop cycle
right.
All these things pull.
What is a subgraph?
Parallel.
It just speaks parallel.
It just meaning it is and edge.
There are multiple edges between
two nodes, right?
So if you see here, it's a very
simple example that is this node
oops.
That is this node and there is
this node between them there are
two edges.
There is this one.
There is this 2 right both of
you are taking you to the same
source and destinations.
So there is multiple edge or
parallel edges, right?
That is what is called parallel
edge.
Since there is no direction in
the edge in graph, there is loop
right?
So where is that?
Loop means usually we refer to
this as a loop, guys.
Yeah.
And this is called a loop,
whereas here this is called as a
cycle.
So I can start from here.
123 I can start from one.
I can go here.
I can go to three.
I can go back.
This is a cycle, so cycles can
be there in the simple graph,
loops cannot be there loop,
meaning self loop.
The two nodes are same for
parallel disk, correct?
What is adjacent over Artices,
Sir?
Yeah, we just learned about all
that.
Again, you are back to square
one.
Be very, very cautious.
Yeah.
What is adjacent vertices?
Adjacent vertices are opposite
ones, right?
You and we are opposite or or
the two endpoints, right?
The two end vertices are always
adjacent, whereas you cannot say
this.
U and Zed are adjacent or urnex
are adjacent or Y and we are
adjacent.
You cannot tell like that.
Yeah.
So we can start and end at the
same node.
For simple graph, yes you can do
that.
Yeah, that can be possible in a
simple graph.
So far so good.
All of you, yeah.
Yes.
No, maybe the definition so far
all these is it clear what is
the simple graph?
What is the cycle?
What is the path?
What is the, you know loop self
loop, parallel edges directed
undirected nodes, edges degrees
in directed graphs we will have
parallel edges but the direction
will be different.
In that case, we will consider
them as having challenges.
No, we will not consider them.
Yeah.
So if there is.
Yeah, but yeah, there are a lot
of examples we will look at it
when the time comes.
But let's say if there is
A&B, right?
So if there is from A to B,
there is one more from A to B.
This is a parallel edge.
Yeah, if you have something like
this.
This is not a parallel edge.
OK, this is from A to B and this
is from B to A and in many cases
you will not draw it like this.
You will actually.
Right, like this, correct?
It simply means that you know
there is a path from A to
B&B to a, but if there are
different ways to it, for
example if this is a tall route
and it costs you 100 if there
is some you know by lanes and it
is continue 50, then it makes
sense to mention this.
But these two are not the same
as what I mean.
Yeah, this and these are
different.
This is say suppose using flight
and this is using train but this
is from same A to B.
This is ballage.
Yeah.
Is it clear all of you?
Yeah, because of the direction,
correct.
But we will be looking at a lot
of examples like this in this
whole course, so don't worry
about it.
Yeah, a subgraph.
Very interesting concept.
If you carve out something from
an existing graph, great, then
that is called as a subgraph.
A subgraph?
Yes, of a graph G is a graph
such that though workplaces of,
yes are a subset of the vertices
of G, the edges of yes are a
subset of the edges of G subset.
All of you know normal Max
subset.
There is a graph.
Vertices are 123456 and these
are the edges.
In this First things first, what
type of graph is this?
Yeah.
Is it, uh, directed, undirected?
Yeah, this is a directed graph.
Well directed simple graph
because there is no loops, there
are no parallel edges.
Also great, cool.
And now if I carve out something
from here, something like this,
right?
So in this case I have removed
that whole node 1/5 and whatever
is remaining is here.
In this example I've removed
just that five.
I've removed some edges and so
one so there can be many
subgraphs for a given graph G
and this is a homework for you
to find out how many are
possible.
OK, these two are not
exhaustive.
There are many other dots.
Yeah, there are many possible.
OK.
But the simple fact is that if
we remove something from this
week, if I remove something from
the edges, what I get as a
result is a subgraph of this
original graph.
This is all.
Yes, this is G and these are
all.
Yes.
Is this clear?
All of you, even if I remove one
edge that becomes a subgraph.
If I remove one node that
becomes a subgraph.
Is this clear? This.
Yeah, you can remove multiple in
this case.
I have removed this.
I removed this.
I removed this whole node.
Many things I have removed.
You can remove many of them.
Also, if there is a graph G and
if I remove all the edges only
all the edges I have removed
then the resultants of graph
yes.
What type will that be?
Yeah.
Will it be a trivial graph?
Will it be a null graph?
Yeah, very good.
It will be a null graph.
Will the null graph be a
subgraph?
Yes, exactly.
That is why in your mathematics,
when you do a subset, you also
put this Mt as a subset.
Did did you get that?
Do you do that in math?
Whenever you take some subsets,
you do you know two power that
many number and all that.
You put a you know empty set
right.
That is also the same reason
here, where a null graph is a
subset of these cool subgraph.
All of you understood.
I can remove either age or a
vertex or both.
Any number of things I can
remove, but if I remove
something what I get as a result
is called as a subgraph.
Perfect.
Now, what is a spanning
subgraph?
A spanning subgraph of G is a
subgraph that contains all the
vertices of G, meaning if I
always maintain all the
vertices, VI only remove some
edges, then that is called as a
spanning subgraph, right?
This is an example meaning in
other words I can say that in G
the number of vertices right
this guy will be equal to.
It will be equal to the number
of. Oops.
Will be equal to the spanning
subgraph, right?
Its number of vertices, so here
it is 6 right.
There are 123456 here.
Also there is 123456.
Only this particular edge, this
one as well as this one I have
removed.
Then it becomes a spanning
subgraph and I'll graph will
with all the vertices will also
be a spanning subgraph.
No.
Yeah, all the vertices?
Yes, that will also be a
subgraph, correct?
His total number of subgraphs
possible for a given graph
factorial.
No, that is up to you.
I told you that that's a
homework.
That's not a very simple answer.
It's not factorial, it is not
too power, etcetera.
It's a complex thing, but try to
find out about it.
Yeah, there is a lot of
interesting angle up to it.
If a graph has only one edge
between any two given vertices,
then it can't have a spanning
subgraph except the null graph.
So what do you mean by that?
The graph has one edge between
any two given vertices.
OK, then it can't have a
spanning subgraph.
Why it can't have?
Yeah, I can remove all of them
and then it will become an L
graph.
But null graph is also a
spanning graph, right?
Yeah, you're right, Rajesh.
Correct, but are these
definitions clear for everyone?
Yeah, Amit, I don't see any
responses from you.
Are you there?
Yeah.
Rishi bhadas, yeah.
It's very, very simple.
Yeah, there is no point in
getting confused here.
Yeah, there is a graph given to
you.
You remove something from it.
It is a subgraph.
So far so good.
Yeah, one vertex can also be a
subgraph, yeah.
Yeah.
We will go one by one.
I have a graph like this.
I really say this one vertex,
along with its edge.
Right.
Whatever I get as a result is
nothing but my subgraph.
So basically subgraph means I
can remove some vertices or I
can remove some edges or I can
remove both edges and vertices.
However, I like correct what I
get as a result is a subgraph.
You can have many of them.
Well, now what is a spanning
subgraph spanning subgraph means
all the vertices in this that is
123456.
It should be definitely there.
Only some edges alone.
You then that is called as a
spanning subgraph.
Is that clear?
In this example I have removed
this three to four and four to
one.
I have removed or I could have
just removed, you know, some
other adjacent so one.
Yeah, so far, so good.
All of you.
There are many interpretations
possible, but I'll leave it to
you to do that, but for now I
will make a statement.
All spanning subgraphs are
subgraphs of G.
Is that correct?
All spanning subgraphs are
subgraphs of G.
All subgraphs are spanning
subgraphs.
Is that correct?
All subgraphs are spanning
subgraphs.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
How many of you agree to that?
So correct, because in subgraph
I can remove a whole node
itself.
I can remove 2-3 nodes itself.
That's possible, but then that
cannot be a spanning subgraph,
right?
So all spanning subgraphs are
subgraphs, whereas all subgraphs
are not spanning subgraphs.
Cool.
Connectivity.
Yeah, real quick.
Not always.
Yeah. Correct.
All subgraph cannot be spinning.
Cool. Cool.
Yeah, I still keep, you know,
I'm getting the same responses.
Yeah, thing you can stop now.
Yeah.
Connectivity.
A graph is connected if there is
a path between every pair of
vertices.
Yeah, from every vertex to other
vertex there should be some path
to traverse.
So in this particular graph, if
I'm in any node, can I go to any
other node?
Yeah.
Perfect timing.
Yeah.
Cool.
What about connectivity?
If I'm in any node I'm in here
in this node, I can go to this,
I can go to this and then here
or from there, here or here.
I can go to any other node
similarly if you are in any
node, I can go to any other node
I can traverse then that is
called as a connected graph.
Yeah, this is called
connectivity of a graph.
The graph with multiple
disconnected vertices and edges
is set to be disconnected.
So for example, if you see here,
this is not connected right?
If I'm in this node, I can go to
this or I can go to this.
I will not be able to go to
these parts.
Similarly, if I'm in this mode,
I can go here, but I cannot
reach the others.
So this is called a disconnected
graph, but I have a small
question for you.
Is this one?
This is say second, this is say
you know the first one and the
below one is the second one is
the 2nd 1A subgraph of the first
one.
Yes.
No.
Is the 2nd 1A subgraph of the
first one?
Yes, it's the second one.
A spanning subgraph of the first
one here.
Also, there are five nodes.
Yeah.
Also, there are five notes, so
this is a spanning subgraph of
the first graph.
Correct, but it is this
connected.
I can go from here to here,
here, to here.
But I cannot reach here, so it
is disconnected.
Is this concept clear for all of
you?
Yeah. Connectivity.
Yes, no, cool.
There are two related concepts.
One is called a cut vertex.
Let G be a connected graph,
right?
This is a connected graph,
right?
So is this a connected graph?
All of you.
Do you agree?
I mean any note I can go to any
other node correct if I'm in BI
can go to FI can go to G where
where I want I can go right.
Cool.
Now vertex we belongs to G is
called a cut vertex of G if G -,
V meaning he's a special guy.
OK, if you remove him from this
whole graph it will.
It will result the whole graph
in a disconnected graph.
Removing a cut vertex from a
graph breaks it into two or more
graphs.
Great theming.
Correct attacks will render a
graph disconnected.
So in this case, if I remove G,
what will happen?
Do you will get removed along
with these two, but still
they're remaining graph will be
connected correct?
I can go from F2E from here.
I can go to CBA.
All of them.
I can go and so on, right?
So who is the cut vertex in
this?
Can someone name who's the cut
vertex in this?
So you can imagine these to be
important people in your friend
circle or so on, right?
If they are not there, then you
will be disconnected, right?
Say there are groups of people
and there is one, you know,
important person who's holding
all of you.
If that is not there, then it'll
get disconnected.
Very good CNR examples by
removing E or C the graph will
become disconnected right
unconnected, unconnected, and
two different graphs are same or
different.
Yeah, they're different, right?
In this case, if you see they
are now disconnected.
So in this example I have
removed EI could have done C
also, then the graph would have
been the opposite right?
In this case it will be like
this and here it will be full.
Something like that.
So see RE.
Yeah, both of them can act as
cut vertex.
See can be also there or he can
also be there if E2F is a
directed edge.
Yeah, directed is different
story.
Yeah, we are now talking about
undirected ones, but even
indirectly it is the same case.
Yeah, you'll have to just try to
remove that node.
Will collapse the whole
connectivity.
Yeah, but in connect directed
graph it's more tricky.
We'll have to carefully observe
and, you know, decide that who's
a cut edge now?
Yeah, most of you were actually
unknowingly answering the cut
edge part.
Right cottage is nothing but
that C comma E right?
This is the edge.
So in this case, if you see I
have removed only that edge.
I have not removed any node but
still this became disconnected.
So what is the conclusion?
Yeah, if I remove a cut edge.
What I will get is a.
What is it?
It is a spanning subgraph,
correct?
Because all the nodes are there
only edge I have removed but it
left the whole graph to be
disconnected whereas in a cut
vertex I'm actually removing a
node itself.
Then it cannot be a spanning
subgraph, so it's a normal
subgraph and it will become
disconnected.
Yeah.
Are these two concepts clear for
all of you?
In this example, there is only
one cut edge, yeah.
Yes, no.
Cool.
Which part you want me to
repeat? Jagdish.
Yeah.
Again, you are going back to the
same graph.
Subgraph story.
Yeah.
Please listen carefully.
Yeah.
Otherwise we will just end up
wasting time.
Yeah, we will not be able to
learn a lot of interesting
concepts.
There is a graph here.
You remove Lords or edges or
both.
Then that is a subgraph.
If I remove this file, what
remains is a subgraph.
I remove two.
What remains a subgraph and so
on.
But if I have to keep all these
nodes intact, all that 123456
should be there.
I can remove only these edges,
then that is a spanning
subgraph.
Is that clear?
Yeah.
Well, there's some other
question from Manish.
If it is connected from B as
well and remove C, will it be
disconnected?
No.
Then it will not be
disconnected, right?
It should completely become
disconnected, meaning from here
I cannot go to that part right?
So if it is having another
connectivity here right then it
will not be disconnected.
So in that case, how many cut
edges will be here?
See comma E will be a cottage B
comma.
F will also become another
cottage.
Correct. Cool.
Reinforce.
Yeah, a free tree.
Very, very important.
Please don't get confused.
A free tree is an undirected
graph T such that T is
connected.
T has no cycles.
Yeah.
For example like this it is
connected, meaning from any node
I can go to any other node and
there are no cycles also leave
alone the loops.
There is no cycle.
Also, there is no cycle.
There is no loop and it is
connected, meaning from any node
I can go to any other node then
I can call this as a free tree.
This definition of tree is
different from the one of a
rooted tree.
What we were learning in the
previous classes, right?
Trees.
Heaps that is not this one.
This is called a free tree.
Yeah.
And the what we had learned
earlier is called a rooted tree,
really like this, right?
Put is this clear for all of
you?
Yeah.
What is a free tree?
So then both of them should not
be cut edges because removing
one of them will not make the
graph disconnect correct.
You have to remove both of them
only when you remove both of
them then it will become
disconnected yeah.
No spanning subgraph is not the
same as tree, and so on.
Yeah, this is a completely
different concept.
Free Tree is nothing but a graph
in which it is connected as well
as there is no cycles.
Yeah.
What do you mean by orientation?
These two are different concepts
guys.
This is a rooted tree.
It follows all those concepts
that we learned previously,
whereas this is a graph, this is
this is a graph, but we give it
a special name called as a free
tree because it is connected and
it doesn't have cycles. OK.
So far so good, all of you.
So in that terms I have one
final question for you.
Are all trees graphs?
Yeah, it's not to confuse you,
but just for fun, are all trees
graphs.
Yeah, because the tree will
never have a cycle.
A tree will always be connected,
so all trees are grass, but all
graphs are not trees.
Yeah.
Cool.
I leave these discussions here
for us is nothing but again
multiple, you know, free trees.
If you have a tree like this, if
you have another tree like this
and so on, all of them put
together is a forest.
Cool.
So far so good.
All of you?
Yeah.
Graphs so far.
Is it clear rooted is
hierarchical and free trees
network perfect?
That's very good, Sir Andrew.
Yeah, these are hidden things
that I usually don't explicitly
tell in the class because that's
for you to figure out.
Router tree is always
hierarchical, whereas the free
trees actually a free trees, a
graph only correct because the
definition says the free trees.
An undirected graph T, so by
this word itself it becomes
network, right?
It is not hierarchical.
OK, cool.
What are the different
operations that I can do on a
stack real quick?
The moment I talk about stack,
what can I do?
I can do push, I can do pop, I
can do top.
Similarly, if there is a queue,
I can do enqueue, I can do
dequeue right?
And if there is a heap I can do
insert, remove and so on.
But in a graph I can do a lot of
interesting things.
Right.
Return the number of nodes,
return number of edges.
Return a set of vertices set of
edges.
The degree the You know list
containing all the edges
incident upon our text, right?
I can do a lot of methods, for
example in this case I told you
right if what type of a graph is
this one?
Is it directed or undirected?
Right is also small mistake
here.
Let's assume this is H.
Right, this is a directed edge.
So in this case there are some
other concepts like in degree in
degree means how many edges are
coming towards me right?
For example, for a this is the
indegree.
So how many indegree does it
have a?
Yeah.
It has only one and how many out
degree does it have out degree
means how many days are going
out.
So this one is going out,
whereas for see if you see the
number of in degrees one, but
the number of out degrees 3
right there is this one.
There is this two there is this
33 arrows are going out whereas
one is coming towards it.
So for a directed graph there is
this concept of indegree and
outdegree right, whereas here it
is just degree.
So for this it is 3 where it is
3 for all of it it is 3.
There are some interesting small
theorems on these in your
textbook.
Maybe it's a good idea to have a
look at it, yeah.
I can give an edge and ask the
two corresponding you know
endpoints of it and all those
indicate whether a given edge is
directed or not, right?
Give the in degree of it, insert
a new node right, insert a new
directed edge.
So a lot of things you can do
remove something and so on.
So will you be able to write
Python code for these methods?
Yeah, removal, insertion, giving
the nodes, returning a list and
so on.
Will you be able to do that?
Yes. No.
If not, it's a good idea to
practice them.
Yeah, these are all small
operations that you can do on a
graph.
So try to practice them by
writing small snippets and now
we come to the last part.
How do you represent a stack?
Yeah.
How do you represent or
implement a stack?
There are two ways to do it.
Array or El.
Very good.
Yeah, Nandini is correct.
How do you represent a queue?
Same thing I can do array or
linked list.
How do you represent 3?
Again, same thing.
I can use an array or linked
list, but how do you represent a
heap?
Yeah.
What is your reasoning?
A heap is always a complete
binary tree and a complete
binary tree can always be
implemented using a array,
right?
You'll use an array.
Pranav says is.
It compulsory to understand in
Python Java will not work as
assignment.
Also, Java was mentioned no.
All your assignments will be
only in Python And all your M
tech will be in Python.
Yeah, you will not do Java
assignments for data analysis
and all that throughout this M
tech you will use only Python,
but that's fine as I told, if
you have not mastered it slowly,
you can pick it up right in your
assignment.
There will be at least one
person in your group who knows
Python, so work with them and
get it done right.
Cool.
So far so good.
So you can use a complete binary
tree if it's a complete binary,
you will use an array so like
that for every data structure
there is a way to implement it.
So for a graph, there are three
ways a graph representation
strategy, or you can also call
it as how to implement a graph?
You can use a edge list or you
can use adjacency matrix or you
can use a adjacency list.
Yeah, the adjacency list is not
a very popular way.
It is not much used, yeah.
So for example, if this is a
graph, right?
This is an undirected graph with
nodes and vertices with four
nodes and four edges.
So I if I want to represent it
in a edge list, this is the way
to do it.
There will be a vertex object
which will have the element and
the pointer to that vertex,
right pointer to UVW.
Is it this whole thing is also a
list or I can have an edge right
which is pointing to the actual
edges and that itself is in a
list and then again it will
point to the source destination,
its source, destination and so
on.
This whole vertex itself is a
sequence and this whole edge
itself is a sequence.
But this is your textbook way of
doing.
But you know, I will tell you a
simpler way.
Let's assume this is a graph.
So what is this called in
Python?
If you have a square bracket,
what is it called?
It's so no, it is not a set.
It is a list.
Yeah, actually has, right.
So you have a list inside that.
What do you have you comma V?
What is yugami?
If I just denote you comma we
what can I call it?
I can call it as a edge, correct
you comma B is a edge we comma W
is a edge W comma, U is a edge.
So this is nothing but a list of
edges, so it is called as an
edge list.
Right.
And if you see the next example
0112, so there is a list of
edges given to you.
If this is given, will you be
able to recreate the graph?
That is it possible to have a
been our own pseudo code for
tree and graph?
Yeah, let's check that.
But there are other concepts to
be covered, so you actually
implement these in your actual
assignments.
Yeah.
Cool.
That's fine.
Yeah, there's a couple of list.
That's fine.
Inside the tuple you have the
edges, right?
So will you be able to recreate
the graph if this line alone is
given to you?
Yes. No.
You will have 012345 as nodes.
You will try to, you know, join
the edges and so on.
Right.
Cool.
So this is not a widely used
technique.
OK.
But it is still existing, yeah.
What about adjacency matrix?
We will have a look at this and
then we will close it for today.
Yeah, this is a.
This is a very, very important
concept.
How do you represent a graph?
And adjacency matrix A of a
graph G is formally defined as a
of I comma J is equal to 1 if
there is an edge from vertex I2
vertex J, it is 0 if there is no
edge from vertex it to artex J.
It is clear from the definition
that an adjacency matrix of a
graph with N vertices is a
boolean square matrix with N
rows in north columns with
entries ones and zeros.
It is called a bit matrix.
Don't let the about definition
holds true for both directed and
undirected graph.
If it's an adjacency matrix of
an undirected graph, then the
matrix will look symmetric and
diagonal being zeros.
Note if there are multiple edges
then then you can also put that
number, but let's not read the
slides.
Let's do it real quick.
Tell me what type of a graph is
this?
Is it directed or is it
undirected?
Yeah, directed graph.
How many nodes are here?
Amit will tell me that how many
nodes are there?
Since it's a graph, there can be
any number of edges, any number
of nodes.
Also, there is no relation
between nodes and edges, right?
So here you have 4 nodes and
many edges.
If there are four nodes, then
what will be the matrix size?
We learned it as a square matrix
of size N cross N and here N is
nothing but four, right?
So what will be the size of my
matrix?
It will be 4 cross 4.
I limit as ABCD.
I'll limit as ABCD from A to B.
There is a edge here, so from A
to B I'll put a one.
There are no self loops here, so
A to a, B to BC2CD2D0 from 8 to
C there is edge.
So from A to C, I'll put a one
from A to D there is edge, so
I'll put a one, but it's from B.
There is only B2C, so that alone
is a one other zeros.
Some see there is only C2D, so
C2D is a one.
Others are all zeros and so on.
Is this clear for all of you?
Yeah.
How to represent a graph in
adjacency matrix?
What about this one?
This is an undirected graph,
again 4 nodes, so there will be
again 4 cross four.
So from A to a B to BC2CD2D0
because there are no self loops.
A to B there is a edge, so A to
B there is a one because it is
undirected B to A is also A1
right A to C there is an
undirected edge, so A to CC to a
right AC there is A1 and C2A is
also one like this.
You should be able to create.
Yes, Amit, I've just shown that
is this clear for all of you?
Yeah, exactly.
So if you look at this
undirected graphs matrix, it is
symmetric actually right there
is this one one there is this
one one corresponding here there
is one.
So if you fold it across this
diagonal primary diagonal, it
will look symmetric, right?
That is a property for
undirected graph.
If you look at this matrix, that
property will obey, whereas for
this one it may not obey.
Cool how to represent multiple
edges?
Yeah, multiple edges.
You can count that and put it as
a number.
Something like this from V5 to
V2.
There are three parallel edges,
so you can put that number as a
3 here.
Yeah, it will always be a square
matrix.
That's correct.
It will always be a square
matrix.
It will always be a Boolean
matrix, whereas if it has
multiple edges like this, that
numbers will become like this.
Then it is not a Boolean matrix,
right?
Yeah, some bit.
I think there's a lag from your
end.
This is the example of multiple.
There are three here, so I'll
put that three here.
Right.
V2 to V5V5 to V2 are three.
Is this clear guys for all of
you, how do you represent a
graph as a adjacency matrix?
Yes.
No, maybe.
Yeah, there are some pros and
cons which we will look at in
the next class and then we will
look at that last representation
of adjacency list right and then
we will also look at the
traversals, right.
If a graph like this is given,
how do you traverse it?
The you know, breadth first and
depth 1st way, but Sir, it was
supposed to be only one or zero
exactly correct.
So usually if it is a normal
graph like this without parallel
edges, it will be a boolean
matrix, whereas if it has
parallel edges then you can have
that number itself here.
Then it will not be a Boolean
matrix, but some authors will
prefer to write 1 here instead
of a three.
Yeah.
So they will ignore this
multiple edges and they will
just account it as one yes to
maintain it as a bit matrix.
That is also fine.
What is a better practice where
you actually count it and put it
there?
All undirected will not be
always symmetrical, right?
No, if it is definitely.
If it is an undirected graph, it
will be symmetric.
There is no doubts about it.
Yeah, Arif.
All undirected graphs metrics
will look symmetrical.
Simple.
This is an undirected graph.
It is symmetric, right?
This is 111 match this 00, this
one one this 33 it is symmetric.
Cool.
That being said, we will pause
here.
We will come back the next
class.
Uh, which is after the new year.
What we will do is we will look
at the third one right.
I told you three things.
This adjacency list is pending.
We will look at that and then we
will look at two different
traversal techniques and then we
will pause graphs and we will go
to some other thing.
Yeah.
Again, it repeat.
Please watch the recordings
being sync, otherwise we will
spend a lot of time in just
revisiting what we have done,
which is not the best thing to
do.
So let's try to do that.
So all the excises.
Watch out for the assignment.
It will be live 7:00 PM today
and get started.
Don't wait till the end.
Trying to do that and I'll see
you again after uh, you know.
A week?
Yeah, happy New Year and see you
again.
Bye, bye.